[Music]
welcome everybody to the h3 podcast live
today's episode is sponsored by hinge
and hems thinking for them
today's guest is Tim Heidecker the
triple-threat I would even say musician
actor comedian in my humble opinion one
of the most influential comedians of our
generation can I say that yes the demon
I would say one of the most okay I can't
think of a more influential one off the
top of my head in my life but I can
definitely tell you on my part that I
wouldn't be in comedy today I think if
it wasn't for your this fine man's
influence though thank you to that
check out Tim's live tour on cinema live
check out Tim Heidecker and Greg
turkleton live go to Tim Heidecker
dot-com slash events for dates and
tickets all right well thanks for having
me very grateful and very own yeah I
know it's always tough to get through
that what do you think about that intro
was it too much it's very sarcastic I
assume not okay I know yeah okay good
[ __ ] [ __ ] already [ __ ] I'm trying to put
you at ease yeah I don't want this to be
uncomfortable I want this to be a
positive experience for you most
important okay thank you I well that's
I'm glad to hear that because I have to
admit that I was nervous I mean you sure
yes I was nervous but I'll tell you why
because I wasn't sure which Tim I was
gonna get I know you know what I mean
the real Tim or the interview Tim the
interview Tim it kind of makes like a
parody of how it goes but I feel like
I'm in a different place right now
really well if I do I sigh we have some
mutual friends and and I've you know I'm
interested to talk to you in a open and
frank manner thank you any kind of
aggression confusion well you said
you're in a different place what does
that mean well I mean I guess I've done
a fair amount of the kind of Kaufman
esque
interview uncomfortable right interviews
which are fun sometimes and funny
sometimes result in funny content
absolutely content death no I've enjoyed
watching them so I feel like I've done
that I've done enough of that where to
keep doing it sometimes becomes
redundant and I'm sure as much fun and
and now that that that maybe I've made
enough stuff that there is interesting
things to talk about maybe it's an
interesting experience to watch me talk
about things and more of a sincere
fashion is it is it harder for you to be
is it easier and a way to do interviews
under that Coffman ass kind of no it's
it's actually a little easier to do it
this way because I'm not worried about
being in a in a bit the whole time
but I will see I mean we'll check it out
see how this goes I think I have a
propensity to be amusing without being
confrontational yeah so but now we're
like very it's funny that we're
analyzing the style of interview we
haven't really talked at all no yeah
just start before play now that we got
that out of the way let me let me ask
you thanks for the coffee
yeah how is it and it's very good good
balance did they could hope it's black
so it's kinda hard to mess up when did
you start drinking black coffee was that
right away or did you wear your cream
first grade Wow yeah you were sipping
coffee first no I mean it's a very
boring question well you were getting
our seat in yeah we're getting we're
tipping our toes yeah you know you are
good yeah who has the braveness task I
think I did it's boring but I did drink
coffee in high school it's a diner level
you know going up cream and the sugar
yeah and then excuse me and then I
stopped for a long time after a very
like anxiety like I drank a lot of
coffee I just remember drinking a lot of
iced coffee one at a movie right friend
of mine and got the full panic caffeine
the panic like overnight
cocaine feeling and then stopped for a
long time but then like you know the
past I would say 15 years I drink coffee
in the morning but to get even to get
even more in the weeds and boring
first of all this an event tonight
so I usually can't drink coffee after
the afternoon you know after lunch sure
but now I tonight I'm gonna I'm gonna
let myself have some coffee so I could
talk very fast during this interview we
can get through it right and I could be
full of what do you have rain fires off
what do you have going on tonight I'm
doing a musical performance for Kevin
MacDonald's podcast about I do know that
show but I don't know them on on a name
basis
yeah are you gonna be drinking more
coffee this is the last cop I gotta come
down okay let me okay I would want to
ask you so I feel like myself
and many of my contemporaries are so
equally influenced by your work how old
are you I could turn into a CO interview
yeah because I don't know very much
about absolutely I know a little bit but
I don't know you'd the background yeah
sure so if I if I apologize because I
probably knows this yeah it's redundant
for them no it's all it's all it's well
I might just be curious cuz about my own
show please please ask away that is
totally fine but I'm 32 by 33 oh yeah
right so we're about 10 years apart
yeah I'm 42 so I would say well
basically people who were in college at
the time that Tim and Eric awesome show
great job you know that's when I
discover you guys and for me I
remembered the and I think a lot of
people do remember the exact moment when
they saw your show almost like on 9/11
almost in a weird it's like wow it was
that formative yeah it was that
formative huh Wow
so tell me about that um I was in
college three am playing World of
Warcraft and a little [ __ ] apartment
by myself and I just was head Adult Swim
on it was like some anime and then on
came Tim and Eric not Tom goes to the
mayor no I can't come came
some show and it was just the editing
the colors the sketches the surrealism
were you a fan of were you a comedy fan
before that yes will you let you like
what what would you be well risk I love
and I love Seinfeld to be frank I love
Seinfeld that's always been my my
favorite mm-hmm I love comedy but I
wasn't so much you know and deep right
but I'll tell you when I saw that and I
was like mind blown cuz I I didn't know
that you could kind of be funny in that
way
mm-hmm and it was done in a way that I
was like accessible to me in a way it
seemed like you could maybe do it yeah
and and it what Seinfeld didn't feel I
can never do that yeah I can never ever
do that no feels so far away yeah
although do you notice now if you watch
it on Hulu it it feels like it feels
like a set now it feels yeah like the
way they stretched it or the way they've
made like a I think the problem is that
all of our TVs are so good yeah you can
see like them walking down that Street
you're like too much detail now you like
Seinfeld you fan yeah absolutely
it's great I could watch that every
night yeah it's probably crazy so good
so basically when I saw that I knew in a
way that I was like oh man I would love
to work in comedy all that crazy like
this video game and you did like it yeah
yeah I put down the video game and I
told all my friends about it too I'll
say I was I was your how was your
messenger that was I was people always
told me is they say I was such a fan you
guys all my friends hated it no all my
friends loved it everyone I would always
find that where people with a low back
end oh my yeah you like that they're
loved to tell me like these backhanded
things I loved your show but my
boyfriend he he that's funny okay I
don't I don't need to know those that is
true I go my my friends a huge fan of
you yeah tell me about you
come on and about those times know that
was the time around when we met and I
was in Israel yes anything was here and
we were talking over Skype like every
day
and he would always try to send me your
guys's sketches and it wouldn't work in
Israel
blobby always like I want to see it I
want to see what you're talking about
like he couldn't stop talking about it
was forbidden fruit it was forbidden
fruit and I think we downloaded a bunch
of all I apologize for that I believe
they were pirated spreading the word you
don't care a bit torrenting everything
at that time that was yes rotted to
Israel and I remember sitting down your
sister and being like you got to watch
this brownie Mountain show and she liked
it everyone was loving it so I'm not one
of those guys but anyway to the question
there the course that is is that first
of all you probably hear that a lot from
people that you have influenced their
comedy how do you accept that level of
praise I mean do you do you accept that
you you know not really I mean not first
of all I think when when we talk about
our work I it is it is not just me it is
it's Eric its John's Christ well it's
Doug Luessenhop it's their whole it's a
collective of people that made that what
it was so I I'm okay it's not I don't
I'm not too you know
narcissistic about it that I'm so missus
all me I'm a part of it but yeah we had
may we so much of that period was making
stuff it's in such an insular way in
such a for ourselves that whether people
dug it or not was kind of not as
important to us right now and we prided
ourself on that that we were not doing
anything for fans
we were not fan friendly I'm not that we
I mean we we were very nice to our fans
I think and but we weren't trying to
please anyone but ourselves so I and
it's cool to have because I had that I
had the kids in the hall we were talking
before the show that I like something
like the kids in the hall we're totally
influential to me and certain like you
know Saturday Night Live and all those
and then you get to meet those people
sometimes in life and you get to share
that with them and it's nice it's
definitely nice I appreciate it yeah
I'm glad that those people are out there
I'm glad you're it you know usually
results in kind of decent people to
interesting I think so but III think
it's interesting what you said about
that you guys were making it for
yourselves because I definitely think
that shows that you almost didn't care
about how accessible it was anyone that
wasn't like initiated or I don't know
how to say but definitely part of what
was special about it to a dick in a
sense that it was very much your own
just really your guys's own thing yeah
we had our strong sense of what we
thought was funny and we felt like we
were delivering to each other that you
know we were making ourselves laugh and
and the stakes were so low I mean we
were on in the middle of the night and
we were given very little money
relatively to make something right and
so it just seemed like we were most of
the time learning on the on the job and
making stuff and if he's especially in
the first season you see stuff that was
shot like in the hallways and like out
in front of the office that was all like
probably a lot of that was like making a
first pass at something in it not
working and then going like well let's
just go outside and shoot something you
know so we were given just tremendous
kind of freedom to experiment and figure
it out what time did originally air on
Adult Swim it's like 12:30 or something
like that at 12:15 maybe it's like
really fun to tell your parents that you
have a I'm on TV on something called
Adult Swim which is what all time wasn't
it was a couple years yeah it had been
around for a few years but no nobody
nobody still knows what I mean yeah it's
like well Rick and more so a Comedy
Central like oh they don't even know the
network they saw yeah yeah yeah and it's
still like people the the funny thing
this year has been this free real estate
meme all we wanted to ask you about that
what happened I don't know I mean it
comes out of nowhere
yeah right it comes out of the reddit
Internet yeah and it doesn't it doesn't
have any connection to the work really
to the original piece or to who I am or
anything and so I had this
part in the ant-man movie and people on
the internet are like did you know the
guy from the free real estate you know
it's like that's so fun and people get
mad about that and so it's a weird thing
and then it's happened to Eric with the
universe thing and you know that's true
how does that matter how does that feel
almost to be like it's like appreciating
a piece without knowing the origin does
that bother you at all um it does a
little bit I think it certainly does but
also there's a resignation to not having
any control over that so it's become
yours you know it's whatever kind of
cool to own the other yeah it's it's
fine I mean I saw a [ __ ] free real
estate mural I love that sketch me too I
mean and like I remember writing it and
like it being such a simple stupid idea
knowing that you didn't have to do very
much to make it work and I want to ask
you about that specific sketch for them
I always wonder like worship as his
minds when you over hi I mean we just
get super are you serious no that's
always the no assumption I didn't assume
that I I did only think you can't be
that creative when you're no not like
that no I don't remember specifically
that idea where your head with that it's
really probably comes down to it's free
real estate let's do a commercial where
we're real you know probably seeing a
late nights I'm corny yeah some real
estate commercial and yeah making that
little turn and then knowing that we
could just go in front of a green screen
for a half hour and we would give it to
our boys and they would turned into as
the bug would say we give them you know
give him some [ __ ] to shine is that what
it feels like sometimes because I feel
like our styles similar yours obviously
being inspired from you but a lot of
times we'll go just [ __ ] around in front
of a camera mm-hmm and then it's like I
have no idea if that was any good or not
mm-hmm but I'm gonna sit and edit it for
a thousand years yeah that'll work out
hopefully yeah I think there we've
gotten more efficient with that
think and ours also our style or
interest in what we want to make has
changed a little bit so there's some
stuff we've done that's more conceived
and thought out and planned and then
that becomes pretty much what you
intended it like that time story yeah
yeah it's like only planned oh yeah it's
like not that different than the script
and great things happen in the Edit but
but then yeah there are certain lots of
great moments from awesome show that
we're just like I don't know if I can
put on some crazy wig and you know March
around and we'll figure something yeah
right the feet a little a few of those
moments for sure Bob there's this story
I'm not gonna make you tell it cuz I'm
sure you've told us so many times about
how you guys met Bob Odenkirk and you
kind of had would you call it your break
I mean absolutely yeah it was your brain
it was our big break oh just to
paraphrase you and Eric when in college
sent search for Bob Odenkirk
address send my VHS with some your
sketches over the Tom goes to Mara on
the VHS yes well the first little short
film Tom goes the mayor okay and voice
and an invoice EVD for the DVD changed
from VHS to DVD yeah but Bob loved that
he called you guys up and since then he
kind of mentored you and got your foot
in the door yes so I'm curious now that
story is somewhat famous I would say
apocryphal is that the word Dan can we
get a both yes we're good stuff of
legend
do you guys get a bunch of [ __ ] in the
mail we get a bunch of better call Saul
swag are there people who hear that
story and they're like you know what a
little bit yeah it is encouraged and and
certainly through social media Twitter
and Facebook there's more it's easier to
get it's very easy to get in touch with
Nats of it's very easy to get in touch
with that yeah and every once in a while
there's something that we see or and and
we also are in the this business of
making stuff our product
company makes stuff so we are actually
kind of on the talent scout mmm have you
know have you ever found talent in a
similar way that Bob found you guys well
Vic burger is a big one right and love
Vic and I was telling you earlier the
story with him where he was making fan
videos for on cinema and sending them in
and they're like these music videos he's
made that are really good songs and
funny videos just using our footage from
the show and he so he we were just
amused by that and we contacted him and
and had him make some other stuff and
that set him on of course I think gave
him the little confidence it's like I'll
use that one little like yeah yeah one
little boost no it's so true and now I
mean in today's today as you were
touching on it's like so easy to kind of
get a hold of people yeah
it's it's interesting that if you were
like determined and you're make
something good yeah you can get you can
get I'm gonna see it you can and but the
getting making something good is I think
the hard press the yeah the barrier
most people are reductive of other
people's work or they're not ready yet
or they don't have the resources they're
not good enough first or they I don't
know it's just I think it's it's good I
think that there's still a small you
know it's not a ton of overly incredibly
talented new voices still like gonna be
a small one kid out of a hundred that's
got like this new look at something but
but there's plenty of funny people
there's plenty of yeah you know
definitely good filmmakers and stuff
speaking of Bob he's gone on to like
this incredible success has it been
crazy to watch because yeah because
transformation from my comedian to
dramatic actors yeah really something
yeah I mean when we he was in a
transition period I think in his life
when we met him because he had come out
of doing a couple of pilots that didn't
go he was directing a couple movies and
I think he was not really sure what he
was going to be doing
and he was helping us and he was helping
a bunch of other people get started in
the business and and and yeah so I think
the he was I don't know I mean he's he's
got a good attitude about it I know that
I know he's like I'm just happy to have
the have cool work you know I get to do
cool work he's incredible I don't know
people don't even remember that he was a
comedian at this point cuz he's so the
breaking bad guy yeah so right but so
many lives because I was listening by
Dana Carvey was on Howard Stern there
was a replay but I was listening to it
and he was talking about Odenkirk
writing these iconic Saturday Night Live
sketches back in the Dana Carvey years
because he didn't know he was involved
in Odenkirk and Smigel and Conan O'Brien
we're all writing like the this Saturday
Night Live sketch that that got me into
comedy he was there so like he's had
these incredible you know several lives
in this business are you is that
something that kind of appeals to you
because I know you just got cast in the
new Jordan Peele movie which is awesome
you're super excited about you is that
something that you can see yourself kind
of doing is making a switch in a way to
a dramatic actor which by the way I did
your awesome actor thank you yeah I mean
I've been lucky to dip into that world
now every you know couple i weirdly look
at my IMDB page and I noticed this thing
where I've been in two movies a year for
the past several years and that's like a
neat a kind of thing to try to keep
doing ya know like if I keep doing this
I'm gonna start racking them up yeah at
making movies right
so I've this is the first big I would
say big movie were like you can tell
your aunt although you know bridesmaids
was a big movie that I'm in for a minute
yeah but um you're ru ameyn are you not
allowed to talk about didn't talk too
much about it because we're shooting
right now we're actually shooting right
how about the this is part of the Moon
I decided big this is my big it is the
first one we're like they announce you
there's like you know and everyone's
excited everyone's excited that this
that what's his next moving in a be that
whole thing is neat but it's a great
it's a great project to be involved in
examine awful yeah yeah and but then I'm
in the middle of it and it's so great
because it's just like anything else I
do really it's you know every the
production people are great the cast
members are everyone's nice everyone's
like warm and and collaborative and you
know Jordans interested in what I think
and cold and you just feel like welcome
and that's relaxing and that I kind of
like a nice environment well I am super
excited to see what comes of that yeah
thank you audition for that role how'd
you get the role I had a friend write me
and like he was like how [ __ ] are you
yeah because he's also an actor and he's
like what are you why didn't I didn't
even know about this part like am i and
I'm like no I just I just got asked to
do it cuz Jordan wasn't interested in
you playing this beside me in mind was
amazing but you know I know him a little
bit more in the world
yeah of comedy and stuff so I'm not and
he was such a big fan of the comedy the
movie the comedy that was one of those
movies that when it came out again was a
thing that half the people hated and you
know if you look at the reviews of that
movie it's like an they're angry reviews
and we felt Rick and I felt just like
beaten up by the whole thing and like
very proud of it but and but also like
furious that that that these people
weren't getting what Rick was trying to
do and all this stuff but what happens
is like that movie people like your age
and younger [ __ ] like loved that
movie and it meant a lot to them
and somebody like Jordan is like that's
one of my favorite movies of your maybe
not such favorite movie but he thinks of
me through that movie and so I'm very
grateful for that you know are you tired
of being like loved and hated that's
kind of been like the defining
characteristic of like in your career I
mean it's always a good I've always said
for years that like if you're not
pissing somebody off you're probably not
doing something interesting do you have
to put them off all the time I don't try
to you know I know you know like have in
the past probably yeah but like I mean
as a result of your work of people being
like so frustrated they don't understand
it's like do you ever fantasize about
making would you like to be just beloved
everybody loved this yeah I mean sure
but that's just not in my but that
really I mean I don't know i would tell
you like it never happened up until you
know the first from Tom goes to the
mayor and that came out Eric and I were
very excited we made our TV show we
thought it was pretty good
and we went on the message boards and it
was just like [ __ ] you really these guys
have AIDS
you know these guys Adult Swim forum
well yeah message I don't know there's
such a tough crowd oh my god it was like
it was a and it was just like a flood
there's like one after the other and
that was when we learned that this is a
cruel business I mean like no but but
our macho side was like good [ __ ] them
[ __ ] that yeah we're pissing you off and
then we kind of embraced that a little
bit but it still hurts it doesn't
because you just want to be like I make
you laugh yeah and to make us laugh also
if you don't like it I mean just don't
be known why you care about it I mean
there's plenty of things I don't like I
don't that doesn't make me laugh I never
like rage doesn't make me go on a
message board and
I hate the King of Queens do you are you
at the point or do you know like I'm
just wondering like do you feel like
those kind of comments don't get to you
anymore
when you get into stuff no because it's
now become and that's why I've kind of I
try to get off the the social media
Sonia yeah taking Twitter breaks me
talks you talk I've done personal yeah I
do take it personally I've been a honest
about that I do take it personally and
then I'm in a there's a cycle now of
people who are like I used to be your
biggest fan and now you suck and that's
like my god
that's I don't know if that's worse or
well how does that feel I mean like
genuinely how do you know when people
tell you that it it depends like if it's
something that's that I know is a little
risky that I'm doing that's a little
self a little personal or something
especially my music you know right I put
on my music and litical and I'm very
yeah and the and which obviously has a
tendency to yeah people that are that
get upset about it yeah but you know
it's all personal taste and I know the
music I make is not the it's not popular
music anyways you know it's like a kind
of music I love but it's not so people
like this sucks
then I get it but I also doesn't you
never want to hear you don't want to
hear that yeah yeah rather not hear it
and the easiest thing to do is just to
not public about how I it wasn't even
like that I wanted to I needed to stop
engaging in reading in comments and I've
and it's funny to say but I've seen it's
been a process for me to unstick myself
because you been trying to not do it for
like a year
mmm-hmm I'd say in the past couple
months I've been successfully really
bored like completely but I like in
between that process I would read
comments of like and this should just
really upset me like what do you guys
think about h3 not reading comments
anymore it's like well it's not doing
him any good and it's like you can read
probably
20 positive things of course own cars
and the matter why is that them realize
that I know I don't know and it really
disturbs me yeah I don't know 20 people
change my life I was gonna kill my son
I've gotten that thing Xia idiot nothing
I do have the funniest often the
funniest fans like especially the on
cinema crowd love you there they're
[ __ ] hilarious and they contribute to
sort of the the jokes and the story in a
way that's like I I would want to hang
out with a lot of those people you know
so I don't want to it's it's a it would
be too bad to totally I know yeah
Michael Jackson and lock myself up yeah
cuz I also tried to completely not read
anything and they've started to feel
really like disconnected um everything
which also didn't feel right but there
are human being is you can meet or be a
be around I mean my I try to oh I'm not
on the internet oh I'm actually playing
with my daughter more somehow well have
the guys filter some comments to me but
I just feel like not a bad ideas you get
like yeah I just yeah I get only the
good and and and it's like somebody says
like oh you died of AIDS I think you
have AIDS and you're awful person and
downs like this guy didn't didn't like
the video right I'm like okay right you
know you give you yes and they're also
13 years old and when I was 9 years old
not all of them but I know I used to do
terrible and this was when the internet
was just beginning AOL chat room yeah I
would I'll tell you the worst thing I
ever did tell me I went into this soap
opera chat room okay like back in those
days you have like chat rooms but what's
with topics AOL and I created a persona
that was like a mom and I started typing
like um my baby my baby's choking my
baby's choking very like you know call
the ambulance I'm like what should what
do I do
she's turning blue and this and the joke
to us was like why would I be
that is pretty few no that's the worst
thing you Donna I mean you're sweet
probably more but I think you do strike
on a good point is that like sometimes I
read I mean I'll brush over 20 idiots
that like me
mm-hmm I'll be like oh that guy just
likes me but the thing you don't know
about that guy because it's the [ __ ]
Internet and he could be a 10 year old
beater work could be the same guy ten
times with ten different accounts right
anyways let's stop talking about this I
can't imagine well it's where relatable
to most people I think listen cuz you
want to go back talking about coffee no
just being like if you're a guy out
there with ten followers who wants to
make stuff he's like I'd be so happy to
have people hate my work if they would
actually say grass is always greener
anyway we are at a perfect time for a
break but we got a ton of more questions
coming up guys do not go away and we
will be right back after this short
commercial break
thank you to hinge for sports
this episode hinge is a dating app that
promotes healthy relationships of all
kinds it's a dating app for people
looking for a real relationship with a
partner now I'm a married man so I was
browsing hinge with Dan and I got a say
compared to what I've seen of other
dating apps it's better okay just
straight up there's more information
it's a less superficial and there's a
perfect balance between seeing okay look
I admit you got to be attracted to the
person that's important but you want to
know a little bit more about or they
cute
were they into what kind of hobbies they
have all this stuff it's perfectly
presented there before you give them
that proverbial swipe into oblivion
okay now why should you believe me that
hinges better and offers healthy
relationships how about this fact eighty
percent of hinge dates are rated four or
five stars by real users that means that
people go on hinge dates real love real
connections guys go download it at hinge
Co download hinge in the App Store guys
it's all about wholesomeness stay hinge
to find love find meaning it's free for
Christ's sake so just get on there
give it a shot you Fupa troopers out
there I want you to be happy okay and
that's why I want you to use hinge Co
take you to hinge
do you hear the sound that's the clock
it's ticking for the hairs on your head
you bald sob right 66% of men lose their
hair by age 35 my question to you what
are you gonna do about it okay here's
the thing it's easier to keep the hair
you have them to replace it once you've
heard a lot tick-tock the sweat dripping
down your forehead yet you bald son of a
gun
that hairline slowly starting to move
backwards any bald spots just they make
me read this this sounds really mean I'm
just I'm going with it but it's true
guys because I will tell you from a year
from now is it gonna be usual business
as usual up there are you gonna be a
bald [ __ ] George Costanza ass looking
[ __ ] okay George
I love George but he's insecurities bald
and he's okay that's not the point do
you want a bald spot or do you want to
do something about it you can stop the
ticking thank you if you want your hair
light to recede or do you want to do
something about it first why do you guys
turn to weird solutions or do nothing
when they could turn to medicine and
science introducing for hims calm a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men hey man high
five take care your bodies boys here's
the deal thanks to science baldness this
can be optional hems connects you with
real doctors and medical grade solutions
to treat your hair loss we got well
known generic equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help you keep the hair
on your head okay these are prescription
solutions backed by science
there's no way to groom no awkward
in-person doctor visits you're gonna
save hours by going to four hems com
it's so freakin easy answer a few quick
questions doctors will review and
prescribe you products are shipped
directly to your door here's the call to
action so listen to F up order now my
listeners get a trial of for free of
hims not for free for five dollars
scratch that and put five dollars
instead today right now while supplies
last
that's for hems dot-com slash h3 you get
a month trial for just $5 this would
have cost hundred dollars if you went to
the doctor of pharmacy and it'd be
humiliating now you do it online no
problem no trouble baby go to four hems
calm slash a tree that's fo
our hims calm / h-34 him calm / a free
we're back with the great Tim Heidecker
whose notes and well what I want to say
is go on over to Tim Heidecker comm
slash events gonna crash the site
don't blow it up guys get some tickets
Tim Heidecker and Greg turkleton are on
cinema live experience live live it's
inexperience it really is basically an
off-broadway show head on over we we
were just talking about on cinema yes
which is such a it's been such a wild
ride and then yeah my question with on
cinema now for you guys that don't know
started as a movie review it still is
essentially Brad but it was just a
couple guys we own films but he's been a
lot of twists a lot of turns yeah a
couple of tribulations was it always
your intention from the beginning that
it would have this kind of story arc to
it no that kind of just hasn't why no
the story there is Greg and I were both
on the comedy the movie the comedy that
we talked about earlier and as you do
with movies you have a lot of downtime
there was this feeling at that summer of
there being kind of a overabundance of
podcasts medians just the Marc Maron
thing had been kind of blowing up and
there was this like - Greg and I at
least it felt like there was too many
voices piping in about garbage you know
and so we had just idly out of we had
this idea of doing this movie review
thing and we did it on my phone so like
the first five episodes of the podcast
or these three-minute like let's talk
about ghostbusters and then like not
really knowing much about roast Busters
and it was just kind of but we yeah we
started doing longer versions of that
and in that setting when we were back in
LA and my studio we developed kind of a
couple of personas that started
developing there and then yeah I think
we realized that these guys
that we could tell stories through these
episodes that could be talked about you
didn't have to actually see happen you
know you could just say what kind of
what we did off-camera
be talking about them and you could
almost create these you this these this
drama that you didn't have to actually
shoot were actually produce became like
a radio play and and it just kind of
naturally happened just to probably fill
because the we didn't want to just make
it this one joke of guys who probably
haven't seen the movies giving good
reviews so yeah it became kind of after
a couple seasons I think we we saw what
the potential of these two characters
and it could it could go anywhere and
it's been the I think the most fun
creatively stimulating project for me
ever
yeah Wow yeah just because it it's such
a fun character to be and it's a and
Greg really is I think the funniest
person in the world really he's a great
foil I mean you guys yeah and so and it
exists on this in this form that like it
can exist on Twitter it can exist in the
show itself lie it can be this this soap
opera it's like we've gotten to make a
soap opera right that can go forever
yeah that's true
that's a that is very liberating and you
know the culmination of one of the
recent yeah arc being the trial yeah for
former for those twenty vanquish poor
souls yeah that was incredible that
really woman I've never seen anything
I've genuinely never seen anything like
that I know and I hate like being like
so boy so kind of boastful of my own
stuff sure but somebody has to I know
but again it goes back to the thing I
was saying earlier with awesome show
it's as collaborative yeah thing that
I'm so proud of Erik nor Nikola
who directs it and writes with us and
Craig and our producer Andrew and these
people that make that possible so I feel
like it's my job to come out and help
you got out but it does feel like we put
that out we put we made that and I've
heard it from people like you and we
feel it we're like this isn't what
there's nothing else like just yeah and
the concept alone of seeing you saying
in a courtroom like and like playing it
all extremely straight it's like but no
people like oh Dan Kirk who was always
sort of checking in with me and I'm
checking with him about stuff you know
he wrote me just being like this is like
the best thing I've seen you do and for
in a long time that that meant that's
exciting to me cuz I'm like yes I feel
that way too but it's also a thing where
it's like it doesn't get it doesn't get
treated like anything else either
because it's not you know I don't care
about awards or anything but like it
isn't a TV show it's this thing that
that people end up watching on YouTube
you know as it's five hours folks so
it's like it's a yeah it's a thing that
you you have to commit to yeah but I
don't know we're extremely proud of it
good and want to do some more things
like that yeah we're like oh this is a
fun the other had other people have said
like what a great environment to do
comedy and just this yeah a trial where
you know you you just set up and it was
so fun to make because we just did it in
a courtroom that was unused it was like
you know a real courtroom that had been
I guess abandoned or something but but
we just said you know like this year
he's set up but five cameras and then
just did this play every day for like
three days I wish you guys plan it out
it was planned out
it was pretty planned out but not I
would say not written not dialogue
written be he got planned yeah cuz we
didn't we had cast people that knew not
to give too much away but we we cast
people that knew how to behave in that
environment
and let them and by the end of the
couple days I mean everybody was like
this is so fun we're mate we're just
we're playing it's playing you're
playing yeah and if there was an outtake
version of that you'd see much lotsa
lots of lots Brian laughing lots of yeah
lots of like whatever you know do you
what do you think about like how do we
how do we duck this is so good I'm so
out of it how do we get more people to
watch this yeah I mean it's very its own
specially with on cinema it's been this
sort of frustrating it's not for
everyone but the people that that love
it really care about it and breath
support it and wait different ways and
and feel like it's the greatest thing so
I'm happy for that I wish it was you
know millions of viewers but it's it's I
understand that it's a it's a
contentious dry watching bad people
watching kind of negative it's like it's
like a it's a kind of comedy that's like
that that kind of bio list kind of grow
like nut gross but just kind of like
creates uncomfortable and that's been
our whole career in various forms so I
understand that some people maybe have
enough [ __ ] going on in their real life
yeah that they don't have the luxury of
just like relaxing to that kind of humor
why do you think that you guys have
always had that fascination with like
and and you see it in the other shows
that you guys produce as well I don't
think that absolutely yeah is a is a
real focus on like discomfort mm-hmm
cringe for lack of a better word you
know what is that was I I mean I don't
know it comes probably from the kind of
comedy we liked some of it some of it
like you know Albert Brooks like Albert
Brooks is lost in America movie which i
think is maybe my favorite comedy film
isn't every scene is the kind of scene
that makes your stomach kind of hurt
straight it tenses you up it's like oh
no don't go there don't say that so some
of that there's some of
that most of its probably though just in
awesome show at least it's like creating
absurd situations that go dark for very
not very logical reasons and real
realistic reasons but yeah I don't know
it's there's something I think it's also
like a fundamental comedy construct of
failing is funny of some failure like
Luke slapstick comedy is is violence and
you know somebody's slipping on a banana
peel or falling down stairs is
essentially them failing somehow you
know and so we're doing it on more of
like an emotional level sometimes it's
just nothing's funny about like people
things going well yeah yeah you know
there's I don't think I'd like to see an
attempt at that but I feel like yeah I
mean there there's kind of comedy that's
like people being clever and smart and
that and witty and quick and that's a
different kind of comedy right then I
I'm not that I'm Little Big Bang if ya
quippy you know cute well let me ask you
about absolutely because I am a huge fan
mm-hmm of everything you guys produce I
mean predominantly you guys have two
huge shows right now that I think a lot
of people are talking about which is
Eric Andre show Natan for you mm-hmm I
want to ask you questions about this
shows but how are you involved like
personally in the planning conception of
these not not very much at all really
no we're pretty removed our producing
partner Dave Kneebone you know we
started he's a little more involved than
we are but we we essentially started the
company in the second season of Tom goes
the mayor because we had terrible
experiences with another production
company all right and really saw that
there wasn't much to it you just needed
to kind of like hire a manager you know
and get in somebody to manage that kind
of that side of the books so we started
that just to produce our own stuff and
then after awesome show wrapped we won
we Eric and I needed to take some time
because we wanted to make a movie
and we needed to kind of write the movie
and and think about it and develop it
and another show came in that was
looking for a producer and that was the
John Benjamin has a van show and that
that for our from our perspective it was
we could keep all of our talented people
working while we went off and did
something that didn't require their
services for a few months so it kind of
created a gap and then it just became
you know holistically out of that like I
know Nathan Nathan actually was on that
the John Benjamin show and so he got to
know Dave our producer and he pitched
his show to us and you know yeah let's
go around so I it's so maybe a letdown
but we just we what we offer with the
company is is the opportunity that we
had which is sort of creative freedom
and nobody telling you nobody butting in
with their ideas no it seemed like
everything that you guys produced
doesn't have a quality to it mmm yes I
mean it's it's a lot of scenes and
editors yeah is that a group of talented
people working yeah and a lot of them
started with awesome show and came out I
mean most of the people that are it's
editing and directing have come out of
that the most of the people have edited
and directed the shows that you probably
like are had worked on awesome show
basically or check it out or you know
something like like that I mean it's
funny look at we didn't produce the new
Sacha Baron Cohen show but I see yeah
but if you look at the credits of that
there's like four guys Nathan Nathan
Eric Cantor Nicola who directs all the
Oliver on cinema mm-hm and Becker and
was and also worked on these are your
employees they they have been at points
yeah there would be freelancers mostly
but just yeah it's like a small group of
guys you know mostly guys coming out
editors and and producers and writers
but you you make like a editorial
decision like on a pitch like if
Nathan's like hey about this concept I
don't you don't know
no nothing to do with how do you decide
what show what's your what would you
know how does absolutely decide what it
wants to produce oh we don't decide I
mean we we don't have that that luxury
we have people mean people now we do a
little bit but we take people come in
pitch us ideas yeah we sometimes have
you know we're developed it's there are
certain things are like Nathan's show is
really what Nathan wants to do or and
it's his vision and you already know him
and we know him and we and and and then
you've involved a network like Comedy
Central who has their say sure so the
last thing they want is us I mean if the
conversations I've had with Nathan about
his show have been like some some stuff
having to do with like promotion and
marketing where he wanted my advice on
certain that side of it sort of like how
to handle the work getting whatever you
know what the network wants me to do
this what do you think and then watching
some rough cuts giving maybe a couple of
thoughts that aren't certainly aren't
required yeah I mean so no we're just
just saying we're glad to have our names
attached but you know environment I
think our office creates a just like a
good environment for those kind of
people to feel creative yeah wonder if
you're not giving yourself enough credit
in this situation I swear to god let me
ask you this in that case well at any
rate love them yeah thank you and keep
doing whatever you're doing
what's the story behind this I've always
mattered what else going on well that's
my dad you know I see the resemble and I
do not know that it's sort of common
knowledge maybe it for the people
absolutely yeah there's all sorts of
stuff so that's your dad yep that's a
funny home movies from the that day
which was 1989 or whatever it was s in
Florida and I was going around with the
video camera asking my family to
describe this vacation
in three words that was high or
something and absolutely when Eric and I
were just starting making videos I had
recently gotten all these videotapes
transferred or something and we were
looking through them I was looking
through them and there are a few moments
where I was like this is great gold
right now and one of them was that one
was my poor sister at a recital singing
some song from fiddler on the roof and
her like full totally [ __ ] up a
second verse and we didn't use that for
anything but yeah that's it and then
that just became pretty early on our
slate and it has not changed
yeah he likes it yeah I think he gets a
little residual check that's he get a
little a little but I think it might be
for a minute there was a sketch we did
an awesome show it was my funeral and it
was when I was dead and I had this great
bloated face yeah and we had my dad and
mom make a like a video eulogy for me
that's really funny
oh that was your actual parents yeah a
little I think he gets a little a couple
cents out to me cuz it's he did this the
most sort of insincere like oh well we
wish you the best and thinkety you know
take care and you'll be missed
it's like really tell me how was your
relationship with your dad you got a lot
of dad joke a lot of dad jokes in your
content which I'm a big fan of about
that dad
mm-hmm want to meet that dad yeah it was
mutual with Eric and I we both had this
sort of we love our dads we could I
think we have a good relationship with
our dads I have a better relationship
with his dad I think we've just always
it's been a funny
it's kind of weird cuz it's now kind of
like a common understanding a comedy
comedy concept of dad
the jokes that I think once something
gets into like the world of like Levi's
jeans or commercial you know stuff it's
like yeah it's fully matured into its
own yeah but for us it was just
something there's nothing awkward about
the relationship an adult man has been
his dad like it's it can be it can be
awkward it can be just like well now
we're just two adult men in have
different tastes and I don't know
there's just something as me now being a
dad I get it - it's like you feel a
little unnecessary you can't be like a
degree and no the four know if she just
turned my daughter Amelia just turned
five yesterday just kidding
and then I have a son who's about to
turn two in October what a wonderful I
mean how was it how was a fatherhood
it's great mezack changed your sense
economy of what's funny and kind of
giving you new not really same old same
old I know I'm when amelia was born if
you look at the third or third season of
check it out
there's diaper there's a diaper joke in
there that's I think one of the funniest
things to ever but is right out of the
the experience of being having diapers
in my life it we got yeah one day
it's Bruhl changing a grown an adult
man's diaper and I want to go back I got
this this video the cat Film Festival
mmm when I ask you some questions about
it so this was if I can pop this oh my
god oh look at this little uh long wing
so it looked like a monk yeah I look at
myself I obviously cut my own hair or
something sorry deviant the brows very
heavy and yeah it was well lit it's
clearly well lit this was this the first
up what's the history on this video
because I'm not
was the final project that you and no no
we had been out of college by this point
I was I was living in New York with my
girlfriend that was our bedroom and we
and Eric would come up from Philly and I
would go back to Philly and we'd make
stuff sort of recreationally for fun
back in the days when it was fun to make
stuff no one was paying attention
there was no chat rooms there was no
message boards but we did I think have
this idea to actually do this cat Film
Festival it was we're coming out of like
the Philadelphia art world a little bit
like in out of college there's a lot of
like trying to like a lot of festivals
and and pretend projects and sort of
like arts events I think was we were
kind of into but also kind of aware of
it being silly and kind of pretentious
so I think there was this original idea
to actually do a cat Film Festival got
it which happened years ago I mean it
really did happen come to I thought we
had anything to do with it well I'll
play this if you don't mind okay the man
of it those who have not seen it this is
what 2001 or so my students know we put
it up later this is Tim Heidecker
interesting and me is like welcome miss
Tim for something when you when you see
like these no it's I've fondness for it
you get yeah and this was all Eric like
look at me I really did have that
picture of me on the wall with my
girlfriend on the other side that was
like ironic you know it was like sillies
but Eric boys chose the story that that
that samboni or that
the girl the ice-skating he says that
that was in there because the Eric would
make like wedding videos and stuff and
and like film people's recitals for
money and now that shot was in there's a
mistake when how was it genuine mistake
and that I saw that and said don't I
don't know he likes to to show her me
with well I don't know why but I thought
I know I thought for sure that was a
school project so that kind of messes up
my whole line of questioning here fine
we did another one yeah we did one that
was about lobsters and film and but it's
odd I mean it's probably applicable it's
not really let me hear it now really
well we've got let's see what's the
story behind this video check off that
one what kind of grades did you get well
is a's always did your peers enjoy it
did they understand it well we did make
a video you can look it up it's called
cat it's called cat Film Fest oh no
that's called lobsters in film would
probably get you there but if you're not
seeing that I think that one we made for
our senior project was like mid mid
semester senior project similar and yeah
yeah there's a little more rough it was
a little rougher not quite there yet but
that one angered our fellow classmate
really and what and what fashion well we
were kind of dicks about it we were
given a assignment to to make so we had
a full year of a film class that the
culmination was making a film making a
short film now they needed a way to
grade us half way through to for that
first semester or whatever so they gave
this assignment that we had to do a
presentation for the class about some
aspect of making art direction or
editing or cinematography and Eric and I
were just so into the idea of making
this film and we thought well this is
what we're here for is to do this film
by the way my films awful my real film
is awful very serious so embarrassed
when you first joined film school you
were trying to be a serious
filmmakers yeah there was this period of
my comedy wasn't a real thing it wasn't
seemed unattainable yeah and it wasn't
something you're always a funny guy we
like hey I'm off yes I'm a funny guy
always a funny guy hilarious guy very
fun um what say yes but I'm gonna make
size flicks but I'll be I'll be like
Woody Allen in the mid seventies you
know I'll be September what do you know
right
I loved Woody Allen and that's why I
kind of I mean I think I wanted to go in
that that sort of direction of making my
own stuff and being funny in that was
there a point during college where
you're like this is kind of all these
people and the people I'm around this
isn't what this is isn't connecting with
me yeah a little bit I mean at Temple
University they were very socially in
inch they're interested in sin sort of
political social justice see kind of
storytelling filmmaking and comedy was
not considered something that you could
do that with it's really stupid it's
almost like they do that more than
anything yeah there's a perfect breeding
ground for your style yeah so and they
were also like technically not capable
of of make you know they didn't did we
hadn't entered into like the Final Cut
Pro era of where everyone could just
load up a bunch of footage we still were
doing like a weird video toaster slash
cutting film so is we're in a weird
place where we couldn't really make
anything that great you know so how you
guys passed you got did well to finish
that story was in the middle of the
semester instead of doing a presentation
on the art direction in front of the
students
we made this absurd film that was me
with my presentation was that there are
lobsters in film and then I could show
you examples it sounds almost like a
conspiracy theory it was it's just like
a meaningless waste of time
like and interviewed some professors
about it and then Eric's was like that
VHS is better than film right and we
just made these stupid like you'd you
know you could look it up but and then
what we thought was really clever was we
shot the presentation
in the same lecture hall as where we
where everyone else was giving the thing
so that when we played it in the room
right we were in the root it was playing
we were in the room that it was being
played in yeah so and then it had this
musical interlude of us like dancing and
it was just like very primordial I mean
I mean it but they were pissed eyes we
got an a cuz the professor thought it
was funny how well their students felt
like we they're pissed that we got away
with really not doing this you know
they're just angry because they didn't
think about it
and none of them are doing that you
don't hear their names I mean they're
not films a year our beginning of making
videos kind of started at my school too
I studied art and I did a video art
class and I ended up doing like or early
videos and show them in class as as like
my assignment right it was also kind of
kind of like what you're describing
because in art everyone was also very
serious yeah high emotion and yeah I
mean I took art classes and I was just
never very I was never very visually
adept and so you'd take those classes
and my my go-to move would be to like
make something intentionally bad just to
be like well this is my art you know
it's also like I really don't know good
stuff
you're shielding yourself in a way of
like criticism yeah but it's funnily
enough Eva had these video art classes
in collagen I mean I was just emulating
you guys as much as I could because
that's all I knew that was funny and we
just made like they're the first one we
made was this video called chocolate
wearing grotesquely naked I mean I was
wearing underwear and do I bring my body
chocolate I think we must have just
horrified horrified everybody well
there's a lot of that out there
certainly in college is a lot of just
like I'm crazy
what can I know you uh my favorite
anecdote of Ella's college years one of
her best friends and credit to her for
thinking of this idea her final video
was she put a camera in the toilet and
and and filmed herself taking a poop at
the
professors comment which which sticks
with me to this day one of the best
things I've ever heard his note to her
was was simply this
maybe next time less hair that was what
we were up against by contrast I think
that it probably wasn't that wasn't that
disgusting
I would love to never see that yeah let
me ask you did you ever have any direct
oral disputes during the making of
pigment with Tommy why yeah that was I
don't know how much to tell you about
that well why well are there some things
that you you don't like to talk about it
why is that no I I think there's a
little nice to have a little mystery but
I think we brought him in and and made
him the director of that direction yeah
and then we cuz we really wanted to be
around him to watch how he worked that's
really why we brought you know well you
guys were kind of ahead of the game and
then a ways oh because now he's kind of
a superstar he was last year no it's I
don't know it's it's probably back to
that's probably yeah right I mean that's
not gonna yeah yeah I mean I don't know
we were trying to get him on the potty
he lost I mean he keep blew us off twice
really he lost our number oh well he's a
big not the most satisfying experience
yeah I suspected I suspected that yeah
oh how I wanted to know I mean there was
definitely the was so room vibe in LA
you know when we got here back in 2003
so I don't feel like we were we were in
that maybe second wave of people that
were because when we went to the
screenings it was sold out and okay but
all the way back then hmm
so yeah it was fun and then I remember
going the last time I went which is also
several years ago it had like I took a
mean turn maybe it's just the night I
was there but it just felt like people
are laughing at that
woman who was like you know kind of
implying that she'd gotten
fat it was just had this kind of
nastiness to it in the audience is kind
of mob mentality that it was like yeah
about this dead um but it might have
just been the night yeah
tough tough audio crowd but did you guys
ever kind of I mean in the editing Bay
does well I guess you don't talk about
no good
about him yeah I mean did did he ever
give his opinion when you guys putting
it together like how did he like the
piece after it came out I don't know
we'd met with him several times after
working with him about doing something
together and it never it would always
get weird and you know we wanted he did
this thing the neighbors you ever see
the neighbors yeah that was oh we have
yeah we were like what we'd love to help
you produce that and he'd be like great
maybe you can get me you know the right
editors and the right people like he
wanted to do it for like that idea well
and but it is about it because what made
that so special was we're like we will
literally just find you the money and
then you make it and whatever it is
you'd give it to us and we will hand it
to the network like yeah we don't want
to have any we want to like like a like
disturbing a tribe and yeah Amazon I
don't have any influence yeah I don't
try to like replicate what you do I also
don't want to assist you yeah to make it
better but I also understand his desire
to like why can't I why can't we just
have the best people working on this but
then it just becomes like anything else
ya know so I'm intrigued
so we it's just like it became too
complicated yeah I can imagine
yeah that's kind of his style but like
working with people like Tommy's kind of
like the bread and butter of what you
guys did an awesome show yeah do you
guys ever I mean I've heard this Walter
story tell me if this is something you
guys did you guys used to do put people
through uncomfortable situations get a
good for react performance for example
is it true that you would put people on
cranes up in the sky yeah green screen
they get a ride to get
I actually opposite I was up in the
crane okay with the actor on green and
there's just a couple people we do that
with which is to create a it this the
the doug prishpreed who's one of the
announcers on check it out he's one of
those he's like the sports guy and he's
a real straight guys a real like serious
kind of normal guy but when when we we
just have the system where when we're
shooting him we try to create just like
distraction so we can get a moment of
him being like and those get harder and
harder to do the more so we they get
more elaborate just so they culminated
in me with one of those cranes one of
those like change the light bulb and we
just create this chaos and an
uncomfortable environment that that
gives just that little the spark and in
there I like I might something's gonna
fall out you know in that moment yeah
and we've done that we probably took it
too far too far I'm very intrigued by
that you know we would just like there's
certain people where we would just we
may be kind of gotten sick of them and
gotten tired of they had done something
a little bit maybe to deserve it but we
would just like amuse ourselves by like
sending in entre in appetizers while we
were shooting and you know yelling at
the crew like get out of here you know
they're like but he said he was like
creating these little plays that really
were just for us in here and but nothing
ever a thing ever that we felt like bad
about it would always and it always
ended them feeling good and like wanting
to work with us again well that's the
ticket I mean you walk a thin line
mm-hmm because the people that act
frequently I don't know if they know
whether or not they're and on the joke
or not but I think the real kicker we we
have kind of the
same effect we work with people like
that - is it they want it they want to
come back yeah they want to be a part of
it yeah no yeah I mean we've had a few
people that weren't happy with the way
things went and we feel bad about that
and you know but but for the most part
there is first of all we're never we're
never presenting things with false
pretenses we're not saying it's
something that it isn't it's always like
this is a comedy show
it's but you know there's certain tricks
that we do to get what you say is a
little reality out of the situation
there you know I feel is fairly benign
but you know not the most honorable
honorable way how do you find these
bizarre people just Craigslist people I
mean you have techniques what do you
where do you find these folks well we'd
like to say there's a couple services
that people sign up for to become actors
and then forget that they've old ones we
go over like the bottom of the pile like
oh yeah I remember doing that but do you
want me so some of those people and then
frankly
yeah it's we built sometimes they'll be
like an extra that we that had we had
like working background and was like
who's that right brings back in wallet
bring him up
yeah yeah there was a guy in check it
out that we call brown his name's brown
and he was a background guy and he was
just walking behind Bruhl and he had a
brown sweatshirt on it's why we call him
brown we just saw him like that guy have
him keep walking behind Bruhl just like
create a line and just and have him look
at parole and and we're is one of those
things were just zooming in like oh
that's [ __ ] weird and they were like
you stick around we have worked for you
you're recognizing some kind of special
quality yeah just a look it's a weird
weird vibe yeah weird yeah a little on
edge it's usually it it's not it's the
we get plenty of people sent you
know who were like you know their
headshots are wearing a bowtie and
they've got glasses and they're like you
know like I'm the wacky guy and like
it's a special thing you know usually
it's like a normal person now right that
feels like don't they don't belong in
this in this world have you ever had a
bad reaction with some of these people
because they're a little wacky some of
them are little seeming like a little
wackier than others yeah yeah I mean
whacked by a wacky I don't know what
that there's people that you're like
you're like this I don't keep this guy
I'm gonna not give them my cell phone
yeah yeah we're not gonna hang out yeah
but yeah I mean it's usually pretty good
vibes I got everybody you've ever heard
of this this phenomenon I always hear
this now it's like you hear people say
it's like a Tim and Eric sketch mm-hmm
you know yeah have you heard of the
subreddit it's called not not what do
you think about that I love that place
cool yeah I don't go there often but
sometimes I see stuff there and it's
like yeah that's I mean it's that's
where our lot of our stuff comes from
not we don't look there but we
understood the world that we would look
at I've got one video oh cool that is my
favorite that actually was one of our
first big videos was making it edit this
video I don't know if you've seen this
have you seen this I don't think so I
think you'll love it this guy is such a
lonely thirty seconds long yeah I mean
it's so powerful I'm telling you so well
this guy just he just kamd it cuz it's
such an old video but it's it's just a
guy from a documentary he's an ice cream
taste tester by profession oh okay he's
got a little gold whoo no no you think I
have seen this McKenney ionize what we
do is take a small amount right off the
top it doesn't take much that's the
warmest part right here I'm gonna invert
the spoon you know all 9,000 tastebud
Doug with his hairy hoop that part up
sweeteners
actually you know what if I can just
indulge myself here for Christ's sake
the first big video we made was to edit
kind of a though DJ does a little remix
yeah I just sent to Vic that is like a
pretty good example of how we work in
real time 12 million views on this sick
little baby oh that was like I'm ready
are you ready watch this look at the
picture well it's very quick and maybe
you could show your crowd but yeah we
can Chum I just was watching a little
bit of the John McCain funeral the other
day like the procession and you know it
was just on the news and they just you
see this guy off to the side and is the
kind of thing I just capture and send
who is that guy oh man can you see that
let's get let's find out whose this is
it's probably somebody well-known he's
standing right by the car look at this
guy
but like it's a great something there's
a special quality like the world is full
of the Timoner yeah it's all around us
you're the but you guys you're you named
it all right you like put a name to this
strange I guess so you only not know so
here this is my this was my big break
okay this is 27 seconds yeah it's it's
quick quicker than the original yeah
cover all 9,000 tastebud area it yeah
it's grabbing on top that cream pure
vanilla yep that's a 10
I mean while you get 411 that's 11
million views ah well 12 if you you know
if you want to round yeah did get there
well good for you
that was when Ethan was learning how to
edit that's the first video I edited
possibly by myself I think it was hey
well good for you I mean it's great
thank you you've found something
original and no you know I found the
rhythm of that that made you laugh and
you thank you you sure now we see the
original we almost do that editing yeah
what's going on
why is Papa John so funny because we've
also had John's I became fascinated by
Papa John and then almost separately I
didn't realize that you guys were doing
Papa on gags we did it live I think John
Pappajohn I yeah I don't remember it's
just so benign and lame and your company
Papa yeah kind of funny right the gate I
can't remember what our well we started
doing live shows sort of not we didn't
naturally come out of doing live you
know like stand-ups so we were like oh
we got to do a live show you know what
are we gonna do you know and one of that
was one of the ideas was that we would
like throw pizza out basically what
Gallagher used to do you know isn't that
complicated but yeah I don't remember
it's just like the world of the khaki
pants and the bad well I mean it comes
out of that that which we did with the
Shrek videos - it's like a blatant uh
like self-promotion for somebody else
just sort of like proud of companies
this is the corporate kind of like no no
shame kind of vibe that we'd see in in
life you know like a Super Bowl or
something like Papa John's presents yeah
Whitney Houston the whole stadium after
Papa but Papa is no longer in the house
I've been hearing the new CEO is called
Stephen Stephen Papa Stephen know
Papa Steve Papa Cindy well I always
think like why can't why do companies
have to keep existing forever like can't
things just end can't they just try
giving away a pizza Empire these things
don't mean Thing Thing companies come
and go right
not pop glass yeah it's pretty good it's
ridiculous
also I got a couple more I mean we're
pretty much done here okay I'm okay but
I've got some videos that I'd love to
show you if you got some time okay my
videos no ok well Alex Jones I've seen
you goofing on him you have a great
impression yep it takes me a little bit
to get happy to be here he's also been
in a little bit of a goof what he got
banned a little bit of a goof but then
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why
they're doing it is because the powers
that we have the influence that we have
I do reach the people out there scares
scares them too yeah right that is good
well here I've got a little sound bite
here destroy the child he got and but
then the I mean that was you know that
was a thing that happened but then I'm
and first of all let me just preface
this because I don't there's nothing
wrong with being trans okay that's not
the point of what I'm about to tell you
transient or or transgender both of them
are perfectly acceptable but he is
someone who has said that being a
transgender person is a mental illness
and have you seen in the news that he
was actually found to be jerking his
toolbox to transport Oh didn't see
though I didn't know hey Thank You Davis
Jake well he's good I want to say I
don't want to say ruins but I feel like
being banned he had this huge thing he
was banned off everywhere and everyone
was like it was this great social issue
were like mm-hmm freedom of speech and
he was like riding that yeah but like a
couple days later I think he's a meme I
think he's a meme now well he's been
amines and stuff people there's people
that support him but I feel like he's
been did you see the video refresher
have you seen the
were the the fan of his Milo and him are
sitting at a diner and this fan comes up
to him and he's the guy looks like he's
on meth like this Tweaker
like living in a trailer somewhere and
like he just looks like he's got that
thing in his eye that he believes
everything Alex Jones and he's like hey
you know I've been following you for
years he's all like you could see Alex
Jones just like cringing and yeah I got
some I got something I want to send you
I got this footage and you can see the
Alex Jones is gonna be haunted by these
people yeah yeah and and and it's nice
to get a dose of like hey these are your
people yeah yeah go suck yeah well so
Alex Chung by the way he's selling
beauty products called Infowars yes or
women well it's for skin care for men
because I mean he is alpha male yeah
he's very alpha as it gets he's so alpha
that when he watches porn even the chick
septics
this is real a heart attack and this is
fresh news this is today it's a cup from
by the way and well I mean I mean you
know Twitter so who knows I mean it's
fresh ya know well as far as I'm aware
that hasn't happened but close okay
let's see let's see there's been Mayans
products but these are so good skin
cream aloe vera yes you can right yeah
so hey baby
so okay now obviously it was a brief
encounter now what was it that we saw
dan can you tell me what was the title
cuz I don't want to pull up and show
anything I'm not supposed to see it was
something of like Dan tell me what was
the exact I love you could please
it was in insatiable [ __ ] hunter is Dan
I need a I need a direct he's like he's
got some some you know he has to be
satisfied somehow satisfaction well I
mean if watching pornography is fine but
ya know I understood can't be you need
to watch that trailer mentally sick and
then beaten your [ __ ] dirty ass Alex
Jones me
no it's that's good and that's good cake
okay that's so funny that now we can
just see everything in like an opening
windows who knows what's what people saw
on my phone you gave me that phone there
I've got a title for you it's the
naughty tee babe Marisa minx relieved of
[ __ ] hunger by stud so that's that's
what it said on the screen real briefly
is that trans not ET girl to girl
relieved of [ __ ] hunger is it clear like
breezily found the video yeah I saw the
title not ET girl okay found the video
very graphic I'm doing research you know
well I was finding out what's going on
in this world well actually we don't
even need to imagine here's the reaction
because we've got it good and this is a
development they want to do they want to
derive from Fox I mean from MADtv look
let's look at well SAS for we don't
realize it until just now but Sasso
[Laughter]
what's the name of that movie I'm at TV
so so here we go Oh caller asks yeah
this is what again avoiding it and
everyone on the internet was just how he
was caught watching I'm gonna dress
something there we go okay so people
don't get upset about
they can win yeah and also what about
the trans porn on your phone Alex are
you were going to talk about that
article about that it's ridiculous I was
like looking up some report on my phone
everybody's had porn pop up on their
phones
hundreds of times so I'm in the studio
and then like something pops out like oh
my god I looked at it wasn't the news
blurted out because there was nothing
there
they blurred it to them say something
was there when he went to it was
important menu I probably had porn menus
pop up $500 line by the way it was a
fortune detective kind of live and die
by the Pepe the Frog right and so I've
seen their detective work and there's no
doubt that this guy was looking to
relieve his insatiable [ __ ] it wasn't
some pop up it was most definitely video
yeah you know I've seen it right I've
seen the detective work okay there's
insatiable quelle fortune I guess does
something right well that's what and
it's the nihilism death that they love
sure it's just as much pleasure it's
just about getting whoever's no no
alliances or announces oh thank you so
much no I'm the fortune freaks yeah no
they got one they they bought one of
your own yeah but I'll finish it because
he's squirming and it's really porn
because there's people who watch porn
people who lie about it and I was a
great little piece of Alex Jones and we
I do it on my call-in show called it's a
that's the other thing I plug office
hours often yeah it's my little podcast
call-in show yeah what's a Facebook page
real tim heidecker but you're telling me
I should do it here on YouTube I believe
I truly
you can subscribe to the podcast usual
podcast ways yeah but he's got a great
one I used the sample all the time it
seemed good with that that headed or was
he and it reminds me so much of the Ted
Cruz you know I thought he was gonna say
it was an intern so yeah he didn't even
didn't even go that far right everyone
can watch whatever they want but don't
yeah right exactly exactly
well that's about I mean we're gonna end
on that note yeah is there anything else
that we should discuss no I think it's
been a lively lovely chat thank you well
I enjoyed first of all guys please once
again head on over to Tim Heidecker
dot-com slash events let's party party
like a great show no pizzas gonna be
thrown out at that show Oh turn your own
pizza
oh no yeah the on cinema show you're
gonna get some DKR also I'm doing the
Adult Swim festival I should be like
that oh I think we know there that'll be
fun
you know go there with Jess tonight yeah
yeah and then office hours when I have
the time and see me in Jordan peels new
movie March that is where you're still
filming or do not even start no we're in
the middle is that the real time
consuming for him it is not for you no
I'm I'm kind of in and out throughout
the next few months it's it's a little
it's lovely though it's just when you
what when you can do something where
you're not responsible for that's not
every element of it which is usual
yeah to just kind of be happy you know
not worry about oh we're running a
little late here so I just show up do
your best and say god bless is it a lot
of memorizing lines and some but not
much and it's very you know he's not
super specific you know say what say
what how you would say it that that's
cool
good cuz I'm that's the one thing I'm
not good at is ya ya memorizing lines
I'm afraid I could never do that yeah
it's I think it's a discipline right and
it's to get better at it's like you can
train your brain to do that better but
I'm still very very unlike what I see oh
is in a better call Saul his last
episode there was a gale character do
you watch the show yeah we caught up
except over the new app oh you know Gale
character from Breaking Bad that's the
guy that the business now yeah well he
does this thing where he's like singing
all these these chemical compounds - and
he's doing it like perfectly and I'm
watching that going like I would never
be able to do that it would be like it
would be like a week of shooting scene
like the dedication and rehearsing just
for that brief yeah good and I bet you
nobody thinks about that yeah I did
sinking feeling like I would never be
able to do that and what else can't I do
what if I get something like that not
everything oh you said you're a big guy
well Tim appreciate you so much coming
up I mean we're a needless to say but
I'll say it again huge huge fans and I'm
very grateful for everything you do and
I'm glad this was I think this was a
positive experience for you it was
lovely good time yeah coffee yeah I'll
never watch it or listen to it now I
wanted I hope I didn't hurt anybody's
feelings I hope I didn't reveal too much
I didn't ruin I won't read the comment
Vic maybe he's watched me make are you
out there
you're great with one of these by the
way destroy the child your boy some sick
stuff all right well thank you so much
we love ya there in a heartbeat
guys thank you so much for Y instinct is
to be the one wrapping it up I'm such
Adam Carolla on next week if you want to
wrap it up for us ladies and gentlemen
you folks are in for a real treat we got
one of the greats Adam Carolla coming up
next week right here on the h3 podcast
it's gonna be a lot of fun talking to
Adam about all the things that he's got
going on in his career is it on a
Thursday what days that huh yeah thanks
I don't know no it is Thursday actually
well we'll get back to you on all right
let's wrap it up guys thank you for we
will be here on Tuesday as we always are
oh is in the best two week and we wish
y'all really the very best so thank you
all for watching and have a great
weekend and a half later celebrate those
Labor's right you doing a barbecue do
anything for Labor Day any petting and
what's going you got petting animals
yeah
I'm dressing that online oh [ __ ]
what was that Tim yeah adios
thanks guys thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]